übersetzt heißt es er hat Schimmelbefall
in der Küche
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein One Pot Gericht aus
dem Ofen wir machen nämlich Köfte also
Hackbällchen mit Pasta und einer
Tomatensoße das wird ziemlich lecker und
das ganze ist auch wirklich schnell
zubereitet ihr könnt auch super
vorbereiten als Mehl prep und ich werde
jetzt auch zuerst einmal die
Hackbällchen machen dafür verwende ich
500 g Hackfleisch vom Rind 50 g Parmesan
eine Zwiebel ein Ei für Esslöffel Brösel
habe ich noch eine Knoblauchzehe
zerkleinert etwas Salz Pfeffer und
Thymian jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach
eine große Schüssel direkt eine große
Schüssel nehmen alle Zutaten kommen rein
ich habe auch den Parmesan einfach schon
gerieben die Zwiebeln zerkleinert die
Knoblauchzehe durchgepresst das war's
schon jetzt verknetet ihr einfach alle
Zutaten
[Musik]
das war es jetzt auch im Prinzip schon
das ganze Decke ich kurz ab und lasse es
durchziehen und werde in der
Zwischenzeit aber schon mal die
Tomatensoße zubereiten
für die Tomatensoße verwende ich etwas
Olivenöl zwei Knoblauchzehen die habe
ich bereits gerieben 40 Gramm
Tomatenmark 800 Gramm Tomaten aus der
Dose 400g Wasser etwas Salz und Pfeffer
Rotweinessig oder normalen weißen Essig
die habe ich 500 Gramm Nudeln und zum
Überbacken nehme ich etwas Mozzarella
ich habe jetzt hier geriebene Mozzarella
Mozzarella am Stück und später kommt
noch Basilikum drauf das ganze soll ja
eine one Pot Gericht sein deswegen nehme
ich jetzt eine Gusseisenpfanne die kann
ich nämlich auf dem Herd benutzen aber
eben auch im Backofen und ihr könnt
jetzt hier gerne die Tomatensoße ein
bisschen vorkochen finde ich einfach
persönlich besser ihr könnt sie
natürlich aber auch einfach alles
zusammen mischen und in den Ofen geben
also ihr müsst es am Herzen nicht machen
gibt es einfach den Knoblauch mit
Olivenöl da rein
das wird angebraten denn was ist besser
als Rohr Knoblauch gebratener
und das Wasser hier ist übrigens rot
weil ich wenn ich Tomaten aus der Dose
benutze dann spüle ich die Dosen immer
noch mal mit Wasser aus und da ich es
sowieso mehr Wasser brauche für die
Nudeln sieht das jetzt eben etwas rot
aus also nicht wundern es war einfach
nur Wasser aus der Leitung und das habe
ich in die tomatendosen geschüttet
ausgespült und damit benutzt weil auch
das Lebensmittelverschwendung wenn man
das nicht tut ich soll immer so alle
Spartipps sammeln die wir so im Haushalt
machen können
Sparte
Spüle deine leere Tomatendose mit Wasser
aus der Knoblauch dann anfängt lecker zu
riechen so wie jetzt
kommt das Tomatenmark dazu
kurz mit anbraten
dann die Tomaten dazu
Wasser mit rein
dann gebe ich Salz und Pfeffer mit rein
Pfeffer immer frisch gemahlen und ein
bisschen Essig
und ich brauche jetzt eine etwas dünnere
Tomatensoße denn die Nudeln die kommen
jetzt gleich rot dazu immer mal ein
bisschen rühren
aber die Soße darf jetzt hier erstmal
schön aufkochen
und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit die
kleinen Hackbällchen machen ich nehme
jetzt einfach den mittleren
Eisportionierer könnt auch den kleinen
nehmen falls es kleine Hackbällchen sein
sollen
dann die Bällchen schön Formen und
einfach mal hier auf dem Blech ablegen
ich habe jetzt die Soße übrigens
ausgemacht die soll ja nicht komplett
einkochen falls ihr den Rahmsoße haben
wollt also nicht nur Tomatensoße sondern
Tomatensoße dann gebt ihr einfach ein
bisschen Sahne dazu das ist auch sehr
lecker aber ich habe jetzt gedacht ich
verzichte auch Sahne denn ich
überbacksleber mit Käse
[Musik]
dann später richtig schöne Käseschicht
drauf
vielleicht ein bisschen viel Käse
vielleicht reduziere ich den doch noch
ein bisschen aber
okay dann nehme ich jetzt hier die
Nudeln ich habe jetzt hier so ganz
kleine süße wie heißen die denn
Nudeln
wie heißen die wie hieß die Sorte
coppettini
und die kommen jetzt hier rein
ja
natürlich
aber ich übertreibst jetzt mal nicht
denn es kommen
also schön einrühren den Ofen habe ich
auch schon vorgeheizt
und gebe jetzt hier ich mache das jetzt
erstmal schön flach
und dann kommen
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt hier der Deckel drauf
damit das ganze schön garen kann im
Backofen für etwa 20 Minuten schätze ich
jetzt mal zwischendurch schaue ich mal
kurz rein und später kommt dann zum
Überbacken noch der Käse drauf
[Musik]
jetzt ist das Gericht nach 20 Minuten
fast fertig
sieht gut aus ihr könnt jetzt auch hier
schon mal die Nudeln ein bisschen
vorkosten
denn je nach Größe brauchen Sie etwas
mehr oder weniger Flüssigkeit etwas
länger oder kürzer
ja
es gibt trotzdem schon mal Mozzarella
drauf und geriebenen Käse backt das
ganze noch mal mit Deckel ungefähr zehn
Minuten und dann ja 5 Minuten und dann
ohne Deckel noch mal so 5 bis 10 Minuten
[Musik]
okay Murat kommt mal probieren so ich
habe heute ein ganz ganz besonderen Gast
bei mir und zwar mein Kumpel Levent aus
Norwegen hier
wenn man gerade Mikrofon
aus Norwegen norwegen hat 6 Millionen
Einwohner ist ein wunderschönes Land und
man merkt eigentlich immer wenn jemand
sagt ich war schon in Norwegen im Urlaub
das sind meistens Menschen die etwas
mehr Geld verdienen ja und Pädagogen
oder Lehrer sind also wenn er einer sagt
ich war Norwegen denke ich immer die
Eltern sind Lehrer ja bestimmt ja und
das tolle ist dann Levent hat uns gerade
in die nach Norwegen eingeladen also ich
hoffe dass in dem Team zusammen Juni
Juli
juli Juni Juli August
und er hat ein ganz ganz cooles
Restaurant und in einem Fischerdorf ganz
ganz tolles genau sag mal was schönes
Video genau und essen sie ganz ganz
tollen Fisch und Beeren also sie essen
wirklich in Norwegen
gemeint nicht braun werden
und filmen
man kann sehr schwer was falsch machen
bei Nudeln und mit Tomaten
ganz toll
der Türkei ja daher kennen wir uns auch
schon seit vielen vielen Jahren sieben
Jahre seit sieben Jahren
sieben Jahre schon da war die Ella
gerade frisch auf der Welt und ich war
voll muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen es ist
voll selten dass ein Türke in Norwegen
ist ja ja ist ganz ganz selten
es gibt mehr Bären in Norwegen als
Türken komischer
selber
okay
vielleicht auch schon mal Norwegen mal
schreibt irgendwas drunter
in Deutsch
er hat Schimmelbefall in der Küche ja
und an der an der Decke und an den
Tapete aber wir hatten die Lösung
gefunden so kurz übersetzt das war
norwegisch das war norwegisch
okay also wenn dir das Rezept gerne
ausprobieren wollt dann geht auf
sallys-blog.de oder auch Sallys App und
da könnt ihr euch das Rezept anschauen
nachmachen und mir dann eine ein
Feedback geben wie sie schmeckt genau
wenn ihr Schimmel gefallen in der Küche
abrufen
zu tun hat und ich hoffe wir sehen uns
bald in Norwegen alle zusammen man ganz
cooles Video und besuchen ihn dort da
freue ich mich richtig drauf ich mache
das Essen jetzt lieber noch mal warm
okay tschüss
in Nora
[Musik]